[Music]
one of the things that happens to you
when your image is available on the
internet particularly if you have people
who are interested in what you're doing
and are quite creative is they take that
image and generate memes or modify it in
other ways it can be quite funny or or
interesting or other can I suppose you
could have other qualities as well like
grotesque and that's been the case with
me and people have been forwarding me
these images for quite some time so I
thought it could be interesting to shoot
a video about that where I'll look at
some of them some might I don't quite
know what to make of but others I do
have a few things to say so we start
with comparison means these are memes in
which I'm put side-by-side with some
other people usually in a kind of
sequence and fortunately and in these
I've come out alright people seem to
like the work that I'm doing so in this
first one which is I think known to many
of you viewers if you start out with a
brain and eventually you have I guess a
process of enlightenment going to the
entire body these are five people
including myself who do YouTube videos
that have to do with intellectual
matters so you have cliff Sargent first
and Black ponderer both of them I like
Jordan Peterson Ric Roderick who I very
much like and then finally me at the end
of it and so this is supposed to be
conveying something about you know what
what our videos are doing there's
another funny one that I came across I
actually had to get
my son to tell me what these people were
obviously I know who Will Smith is and
it has to do with YouTube rewind but I'm
not sure who the two middle people are
other than that they're they're
important youtubers but you can see that
you know people out there appreciate
what I'm doing in my youtube channel
particularly with the half-hour Haegele
videos that I'll talk about in a bit now
another kind of funny meme or whatever
we want to call it gets generated
because on 4chan people started calling
me the Minotaur of Milwaukee which is
kind of a cool moniker maybe someday
we'll make t-shirts or mugs with that
sort of thing and here's an image but
they took something that I did is a very
early video did a screenshot of it and
put a minotaurs head on me and there you
go I you know I kind of wish that it
picked some other video or yeah video to
take screenshots of but it is you know
kind of good it's dark I don't know that
it necessarily has to do too much with
hasty generalization or stereotyping but
it's good a lot of people know me as
somebody who does work on anger and I
got interested in studying anger and
partly to deal with my own anger
problems so the next one is I guess
you'd call it a meme that you see out
there every once in a while they took my
headshot distorted it made it red and
this is supposed to be angry Greg people
also talked quite a bit about my
perceived size and so I have some kind
of funny images with respect to that as
it turns out I've taken quite a few
photos with people who are considerably
shorter than me because I'm 6 foot 3 I'm
not as gargantuan as this
sure it makes it out to be but I you
know perspective and the difference
between our our key sizes does make this
this other guy look quite a bit smaller
than me and I'd say I think they
photoshopped it to shrink him down and
make me bigger here's another one from a
lecture that I did at Columbia and they
made my body much larger than the head
much smaller I think to make me look
kind of like a a giant of sort so those
are all kind of funny and then you know
of course we have my headshot and there
are some very interesting ways that
people have messed around with my
headshot so I'm just gonna show you some
of my favorite ones and talk a little
bit about them so my favorite one by far
is this one where I've been given a bane
mask maybe I should do some videos some
time down the line get myself one of
those and talking the funny voice that
Bane has but to talk about philosophy
and that one has been sampled and used
in other people's memes as well and then
there's this one where it's not sure
exactly what you call this but they they
replicated the the head so there's a
whole bunch of Gregory Sadler's peering
over my shoulder that one's also quite
quite funny this one you notice that
what they've got is in the middle of my
my goatee a little Greg Sadler face and
if we zoom in on it you can see that
it's been you know given the fractal
treatment where there's a replication
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
of faces within faces within faces I'm
not quite sure what to make of this one
where my I've been turned into something
I guess like a hamster but it's kind of
funny-looking and I thought people might
get a kick out of this and then I came
across this one so I don't remember
where it's from but somebody turned me
into a purple unicorn very nice and then
finally I people
had heard me talk about something that
happened quite a lot when I was younger
which is I would get into these
arguments of people and then I would
demolish them because I really you know
I knew it I was talking about and I
would really go for the jugular
so I called that Sadler izing but people
have started calling that being saddled
because every once in a while you know
somebody will get kind of testy with me
and I'll get testy with them in
exchanges and they call that being
saddled so somebody with the trademark
thing for that and people can be saddled
by the the Sadler so those are all head
shot things kind of funny then there are
a few other images that people have shot
my way I'm not really sure what to make
of some of these here's one where they
gave me Pepe the Frog hands and I'm in
front of a chess board in some sort of
cosmic setting not quite sure exactly
what that's supposed to mean but it's
kind of a cool picture nonetheless and
people obviously took a good bit of time
to create it there's another one here
where I'm being depicted with a
lightning bolt presumably as soos and
again somebody took quite a lot of work
I mean no Greek gods have glasses that's
kind of silly and then here's one I
think you know people know that I was in
the Army and they they've got me with
you know sort of old woodland gear and
I'm not quite sure what kind of rifle
that is it's clearly not not what I used
to carry but you know in
in battle dress and they just pasted my
face on there so that that's kind of
funny the half hour Eagle series I think
is what people out in meme land know me
best for and there are a few really
funny memes some of which are you know
kind of making fun of me and I'm cool
with that in the mix of those half hour
Hagel and so this is the first one I
want to share with you and if you look
at it it starts out what I read right
Hegel's phenomenology spirit what I
expected some sort of enlightenment
process and then I what I got which is
me of a chalkboard a bunch of videos and
people saying what what the hell is this
and sort of giving up on it and then
here's another good one along along the
same lines don't say you love the anime
if you haven't read the manga the manga
or however it's pronounced right and I
told people this all the time you know
the videos are not supposed to be a
substitute for actually reading Hegel's
phenomenology of spirit they're just a
commentary to help people out with it
one of the best ones by far I'm not sure
who made this as a matter of fact I
don't know who made any of these but but
I think it's kind of good that they did
addicts before and after I think if
you've all seen these sorts of things
you've got alcohol weed drugs and then
some shots of me after working through
the phenomenology of spirit they managed
to get me in the same shirt but several
years later my beard is turned gray I
have wrinkles clearly reading Hegel a
good thing for you one of the ones that
I came across recently that that's you
know more complimentary there there's
Hegel right the bust of Hegel
superimposed over over my face as I'm
explaining Hegel's texts and so Hegel is
explaining Hegel another one that was
coming from the recently
released marks movie in Chinese you know
they photoshopped this so somebody is
very enthusiastic about the Gregory B
Sadler phenomenology of spirit YouTube
series lectures this is greg for lazing
and should say eagle for laze again but
that's what we got and then the last one
that I'll show you is a little bit racy
but also quite funny
it starts out I'm just giving you the
Ken Burns treatment here and this guy
looking at one of the videos and you
notice that he is quite enthralled by it
because he's paying attention to that
not to all the partying that's going on
around him so that's kind of a funny
meme as well and there's there's many
many others out there so you know if you
run across them you know feel free to
send them my way I'm sure that I've
missed many of the ones that are
available we always get a kick out of it
looking at it my wife and I and I'm sure
that as time goes on and people discover
all the other photos that I have out
there there'll be more and more of these
and it's kind of a you know I like I
said I don't really contribute to this I
don't I don't use Photoshop you know my
my techniques with this sort of thing
are limited to taking pictures and maybe
putting a little text over them or or
putting them into a presentation line
like this but I think it's kind of cool
that people have been doing this over
the years so that's what I'll leave off
on if you found these interesting
you can dig around and you know I'm sure
you'll find many more
[Music]